[Applause]
hi everyone my name is Leanne grant and
I'm the head of partnerships and
business development at brand list but
before I start talking about myself I'm
gonna turn the tables around and I'm
gonna talk about you I want you guys to
take a couple seconds now to think about
one word and what that word should be is
something that's your intention it might
be something based on the four women
before me and something that they talked
about that resonated with you it might
be a word that you think been thinking
about in your past so I'll give you a
couple seconds okay so keep that in your
head and I'll share with you what my
word is and that word is embrace and
today I'm going to spend a few minutes
talking to you about that word in a few
different ways throughout my career that
I found a way to embrace different
situations and moments and I'm even
trying to embrace how awkward I feel
right now so let's go back to when I was
22 I was fried eyed and bushy tailed
senior in college and I knew what I
wanted to be in life I wanted to be a
lawyer I loved and still love law and
order SVU Olivia Benson is was and like
will continue to be my personal hero I
also took a bunch of social justice
classes and I have sneaking suspicion
that I it might be me who changes the
world and so I did everything that
you're supposed to do
I majored in legal studies I inserted
the American Bar Association I studied
for the LSAT check check check
everything except for one small problem
my personality I would make an awful
lawyer I have always had a problem with
authority I don't like rules I shy away
from conflict and I like a lot of change
like it's such a bad idea
so last number one embrace your
personality and what makes you unique
and find a career that's going to
complement your personality so I'm a
that change and I and I was able to move
out to San Francisco and work at Google
and at Google I learned so many skills
sales customer service spreadsheets how
to write an email how i'm not we had
email quality and they would record here
whatever that was the whole thing but I
got really good at writing emails and I
traveled I traveled around the US I
worked in our India office
I made amazing friends Julie you're out
in the office in the audience thanks for
coming and my favorite part of my job
was talking to all these tech founders
who were using Google's AdWords product
to grow their business and I realized
from that experience hey maybe I want to
be a founder and so I decided to leave
Google and I went to business school at
Yale I interned at AOL I was back on the
East Coast and then I came out here and
I was lucky enough to go work at
PopSugar which is an emerging media
company and there I headed up sales and
business development for shopstyle
which is an e-commerce site and I for
the first time was managing people and I
tried really really hard to be good at
that I asked him about their feelings
and I said cool Hudson and I spent a lot
of time with my team but at the end of
the day you know we were turning out
partnerships and deals and growing
traffic and growing revenue and making
decks and presentations and sending so
many emails we were so busy and one day
I was walking to work and I was walking
to the Eric's walking the Muni and I
love that time of the day I would think
about what I wanted to accomplish I
would enjoy being outside and I my walk
I got a phone call and it was a number I
didn't recognize so I cleared the call
and I got on the Muni I was talking to
my coworkers and that number called
again and so I said okay you know it
must be important I answered and it was
the brother of a guy on a young man on
my team and he was calling to let me
know that that that his brother my team
member had passed away that weekend he
was 26 years old and it was somebody
that I managed and you know I'm not
going to go into the details but it
wasn't it was such a hard situation and
mighty
real from it and we talked about it we
didn't know what to do and so I emailed
his his brother and his mom when I just
said I'm sorry
and his mom responded on me almost
immediately and she said I just want to
thank you I want to thank you for the
opportunity for my son to work at your
company he was so happy and that's all I
ever wanted for my kids is to be happy
what an amazing response when you're in
the depths of grief for somebody who's
probably having the worst moment of her
life to thank me to talk about happiness
and how many times do I get frustrated
at work or something join wrong at home
or like you know something small happens
and to just smile and to laugh and so
that was my second lesson to embrace
smile and Bradys happiness so let's all
smile or look like so a couple years
later I left PopSugar because I was
thinking back to my time at Google and
how I loved working with all those
founders and I thought maybe maybe I
want to be a founder maybe it's my time
now and so a friend and I got together
and we did everything you're supposed to
do to launch a company we did user
interviews and Industry research and we
marketed it and we built a product and
we generated revenue and we talked to
investors and when things didn't work we
iterated them we tried new things and
then it just wasn't working that we
weren't getting enough customers and we
were gonna fail and I I don't fail in
fact at one time I was doing an Ironman
triathlon and I got in a bike accident
and I blacked out and I cracked my
helmet and I got up and I finished that
Ironman I do not think
i I just like I don't quit and this time
I had to quit and so that's my third
lesson embrace the failure because if I
hadn't tried to start a company
something I'd wanted to do for someone
for so long I wouldn't have failed and
so after I brushed myself off got over
myself a little bit it was time to look
for a new job so I opted my resume I did
networking I went into that black hole
of stalking on LinkedIn that everybody's
done late at night and I realized you
know I'm not quite ready to get back
into the 50 hours of working I want to
do 50 hours of something different I
want it I want to become a yoga teacher
and so I did 50 hours a week of yoga
teacher training and I was learning
anatomy and studying Sanskrit in the
middle of a downward dog between warrior
one and weary Oh - I'd like run out for
a phone interview or I'd put my heels on
and I'd put on a dress and I'd go for an
interview and at the end of that time I
had a job and it was not as a yoga
teacher I'll tell you what it was in a
second and that was my fourth lesson
which is to embrace self-discovery take
that time even when you're busy
interviewing or talking to people or at
work and find something new that you're
gonna have for the rest of your life and
I ended up at Brandis which is where I
am now and for those of you who don't
know brand this is a new kind of company
we're trying to bring better everything
to everyone and so what that is is
better for you everyday essentials
non-gmo snacks clean Beauty compostable
tableware tree free toilet paper and the
reason I joined Brandis is not
necessarily for what it does but for
what kind of company it is and it really
ties back to a lot of the things that I
looked for in my past so I felt like
maybe this is my time to really save the
world like I wanted to in college and
we're trying to bring better products to
people and we have a partnership with
feeding America so we're probably not
gonna save the world but I'm trying to
do a little bit of that I also was
harkening back to my Google days and I
loved working with innovative founders
we actually just won yesterday I think
Fast Company
is one of the most innovative companies
of the year and so I love no and so I'm
so lucky to work there and I also like
the culture we have and we print on all
of our products we put people first and
it's really about setting intentions
like I asked you to do at the beginning
and we'll get back to that and thinking
about not people's roles and what they
do but who they are and last I love I
love my role I love business development
and partnerships because I get to learn
and I get to work on the most
interesting thing so new businesses
talking to people I don't know a lot of
things but as jess was talking about
earlier being uncomfortable so that's my
fifth lesson embrace learning embracing
discomfort so that's my career and
that's how I got here today
so just to recap the word embrace I
challenge you guys to think about ways
that you can do that more in your life
so embrace your personality figure out
what role is right for you and who you
are embrace happiness and those moments
where you're frustrated try to smile a
laugh and try to get somebody else to do
the same
I forgot my third one embrace failure
it's okay to try things and it's okay to
fail it means you actually tried embrace
self-discovery take some time out and do
something for you and last but not least
embrace learning try to find a way to
learn every single day so I just shared
my intention with you
and I want you guys to take a second
before the next speaker and share your
intention with the person next to you
and I hope maybe that you can come back
to the stage in a couple years and you
can share your intention with more
people thank you
[Applause]